Cognitive agents too face the issue of how far to generalize.
We can undergeneralize in which case what we learn is not very useful.
We can overgeneralize in which case what we learned may not be correct.
For example, imagine that I was a Martian who came to your Earth.
I saw the first human being, and I may undergeneralize and
say this specific person has two arms. That is not very useful because that is
not applicable to any other human being. Or I may overgeneralize and
say everyone on this Earth has two arms. That may not be correct.
[UNKNOWN] is a technique that allows convergence to the right level
of abstraction. This is also connected to the notion of cognitive flexibility.
Cognitive flexibility occurs where the agent has multiple characterizations or
multiple perspectives on the same thing. As we saw in version spaces,
the agent has several possible definitions for a concept that converge over
time. An alternate view is to come up with one generalization and
try it out in the world. See how well it works. If it leads to a mistake or
a failure, then one can learn by correcting that mistake.
We'll return to this topic a little bit later in the class.